wahrscheinlich ist der beste für die
position des anderen wird es trotzdem
nicht weil die cdu glaube ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass einer der drei
männer in der cdu wieder zur wahl stehen
und eine von ihnen wird ja cdu
vorsitzende das dem dann ein feld wir
nehmen jetzt den csu-vorsitzenden als
kanzlerkandidat das würde mich sehr
überraschen wenn es so kommen wir das
gut für die union das wäre womöglich
sogar für deutschland ein gutes signal
aber ich glaube es wird eine der
verrückten geschichten seien der beste
wird es nicht sondern es wird der der in
der politik sozusagen die geeignetsten
foren hat und das ist aus meiner sicht
armin laschet noch wichtiger als das was
ich sage ist ja wie gesagt das was der
berliner taxifahrer sagte und mit all
den menschen ich mache mir da immer so
spielt raus und jedem den ich so begegne
und dem man so als als mann oder frau
des volkes bezeichnet würde frage ich
kennen sie markus söder sagen alle ja ja
und das ist schon ein wahnsinniger wert
heutzutage fast jeder kennt ihn fast
jeder hat eine meinung zu ihm
wer ist denn norbert röttgen also wer
außer uns hier in der runde kennt der
norbert röttgen friedrich merz also der
hat glaube ich in der riege der jungen
frauen von 20 bis 40 noch größere
akzeptanz probleme als markus söder also
ich glaub markus söder hat schon
wirklich wahnsinnig große chance
tatsächlich auch kanzler zu werden im
nächsten jahr und wenn man sich
vorstellt hat irgendwer angela merkel
damals eigentlich das kanzleramt
zugetraut
ja da waren doch auch wahnsinnig viele
fragezeichen in allen köpfen sie war
kohls mädchen die frau aus
ostdeutschland die frau die ganz knapp
nur gegen den schröder gewonnen hat und
hätte da irgendeiner gedacht die sitzt
16 jahre
breitbeinig im sessel ja auch niemand
gedacht verändert
aufgeschrieben und frage ob er chancen
ob diese und noch begleitet
also wenn alles eintritt was er was er
in aussicht stelle befindet das
gefährlich das worunter dauert noch
lange an das nicht auch dann vorsichtig
zu sein wenn das wenn er das weiter
treiben kann dann hat er chancen wenn
allerdings pro ist sozusagen die
menschen keine angst haben übrigens
interessant wir haben beide fallen
reflektiert auf einen moment nämlich
sein schröder bezug
also hat in diesem ganzen geschwurbel
warum er doch jetzt nicht schon sagt er
will es werden usw
4 plötzlich an über schröder zu reden
und zwar im zusammenhang mit dem
richtigen moment schröder sei sehr spät
erst im märz des vorjahres in die bütt
gegangen und das hat mir doch mein
instinkt diesen zeitplan hat er sich
doch schon mal überlegen